pourquoi tu es le seul homme qui veut
bien rester avec moi
je sais pas
mais tu restes
je reste
on y va
pourquoi maman et aimant différentes
combien d'autres personnes
je crois que c'est sa façon d'être
ce que tu m'aimes
je suis fou de toi
tu t'es pas là c'est
non
et le fait que cela gêne pas du tout
s'afficher avec tous ces types devant
nous tu vaux mieux que ça
elle est différente
c'est ce qui me plaît chez elle
[Musique]
je veux que ma vie soit une source de
plaisir
t'as pas envie de m'expliquer pourquoi
t'es pas rentré de la nuit non pas
vraiment c'est pas je mérite pas c'est
un jeu depuis le début
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à temps plein
tu veux que je te dise
[Musique]
si tu avais et poser n'importe qui
d'autre
avis aux rétais fientes que tu te serais
foutu en l'air
tu crois qu'un jour en serais heureux
tout simplement en tout cas je perds pas
espoir